Now that we have seen some examples of semantic networks,
let us try to characterize semantic networks as a knowledgeable presentation.
A knowledgeable presentation, will have a lexicon. That tells us
something about the vocabulary of the presentation language. A structure
which tells us about how the words of that vocabulary can be composed together
into complex representations and the semantics which tells us how
the representation allows us to draw inferences so that we can in fact reason.
In case of semantic network the basic lexicon consists of nodes that
capture objects. So, x, y, z. What about this structural specification?
Structural specification here consists of links which have directions.
These links capture relationships and allows to compose these notes together
into complex representations. What about the semantics? In case of semantics,
we are going to put labels on these links which are then going to
allow us to do, draw inferences and do reasoning over these representations.